I want every American to be prepared for
the hard days that lie ahead we're gonna
go through a very tough two weeks and
then hopefully as the experts are
predicting as I think a lot of us are
predicting after having studied it's so
hard you're gonna start seeing some real
light at the end of the tunnel
let's bring in Kellyanne Conway she is
the counselor to the president good
morning tea Kellyanne
good morning good morning so that was a
sovereign message and then the extension
the pause is now extended to the end of
the month what does the next four weeks
look like we he said these next two
weeks are gonna be pretty bad pretty
painful for all of us but what happens
at the end of the month we'll have to
see and the reason that the 30 days was
expanded on top of the original 15 is
because these mitigation tactics work
and it's so great for the American
people to know that they are part of the
solution if you stay six feet apart from
someone if you're doing that social
distancing regularly if you're staying
inside is you've been asked to do by the
federal government and certainly by
yours by your governors and local
leaders then you are helping to slow the
spread we've seen the positive results
of that and as I sit in the task force
meetings every day as I talk to our
scientists and other health
professionals there's really no
substitute for that and I think often
Americans are told your this is the
problem this is the challenge do this do
that but here we're part of the solution
so the old saying prevention is an ounce
of cure that's really true of mitigation
here in addition as the president goes
out there and talks about every day
gives the progress report of the
regulations the red tape that have been
reduced or the emergency approvals the
FDA has done on a rapid test you can get
the results in minutes on the
convalescent plasma for some seriously
ill patients and some other approvals
sterilization of masks for example all
these emergency approvals all of the
lifting of the regulations in red tape
off of our hospitals and health care
workers sometimes this takes years it's
taken a matter of weeks
so the billions of dollars that have
been invested than millions of supplies
that have been deployed the thousands of
military doctors and and National Guard
the dozens of companies that have
stepped up some of who have been
highlighted some who don't
any credit don't need it just want to
help it's really been an incredible
effort on behalf of America but the
president the United States and our
commander in chief standing up and
saying the next couple of weeks are
going to be brutal tells us all how
important it is that we pay attention
and we comply with some really simple
asks might not surprise you
but the former Vice President Joe Biden
very critical of the president's hit
president's handling of this and he
brought up an idea he said the president
should call up President Obama for help
Willie well the president was asked that
question I think it's really
disappointing to have President Obama's
number two who apparently doesn't talk
much to him out there criticizing
instead of saying hey here's what we did
that we thought was effective why does
it vice president biden call the White
House today and offer some support he's
in his bunker in Wilmington and I have
to tell you we're not talking about
politics here at the White House at all
we're talking about ventilators and
vaccines not Biden and Bernie there's
really no time for that but it's very
disappointing when you see the criticism
I think the critics and the naysayers
seems so much more small and so much
more shrill and unhelpful and petty than
they ever have
speaking of Democratic leaders though I
have to tell you sitting on these calls
with the president the vice president
and the governors I have to tell you
that the ones that leaked the audiotape
and try to get the information and going
all the TV shows hooray instead of being
on the ground with with FEMA with the
patients and hospitals and health care
workers and first responders I want to
point out to you something that has not
been revealed there were four
consecutive female Democratic leaders
the mayor of DC the governor of New
Mexico followed by the governor of Maine
and then the governor of Guam four
Democratic female leaders in a row on
that call two short days ago thanking
the president the vice president the
task force for providing information
supply services and then making specific
asks but there were there are no
politics for them on that phone call
they're saying thank you so much for the
federal government's response here's
what my state my territory the District
of Columbia needs next thanking for the
29 emergency disaster declarations that
have been approved
thanking for the title 32 approvals
thanking the fact that we've got we're
converting hotels to hospitals that
these regulations that prevented clinics
and surgical centers and dormitories
from being stand-up health healthcare
providing facilities are they're able to
do that now
so it's regulation after regulation move
after moved and I think the critics seem
small I guess I would ask Vice President
Biden why he can't call and lend a hand
and isn't it at a time doesn't he think
he would actually do better by calling
her and trying to help but really what
would he say what would he have to say
the president's our president's made
very clear that he feels that we were we
were we inherited about a bad and broken
system and that's true I mean the
testing ecosystem and the surge of
supplies that we've been able to do in
short time is impressive but it needs to
continue because people still need
supplies testing 1.1 or 1.2 million by
today people particularly health care
workers are first responders but making
sure that people who need a test who
have the symptoms who help care
professionals that said you should get a
test are getting that test and Admiral
Schwarz did a fantastic job in a short
time coordinating that Kellyanne today's
a tough day it's April 1st
forget about April Fool's Day it's the
day that rent is due for a lot of people
and there are a lot of small businesses
across the country they're trying to
figure out what do we do they're still
waiting for their checks You Know Who am
I gonna have to layoff who am I gonna be
able to keep I know you're in those task
force meetings and I know this is a big
concern for the task force and the
country as well for the small business
people who are looking in on this
Wednesday morning what's your message to
them my message to them is please take
advantage of the over 370 million
dollars a billion dollars that that is
in the latest package for them and they
need to get in touch with the Small
Business Administration the Department
of Treasury is also managing that folks
don't feel like you're getting a handout
from the government don't be proud this
is this is for you this is because you
are an economic
our streets temporarily through no fault
of your own and the Paycheck protection
piece of this is meant to sustain them
so they can keep the payroll they can
keep people working I also would would
say how great it is that the that the
nonprofit's are included in that now
because our nonprofits provide such
important services to our communities
including daycare and food banks for
example so they will be able to continue
but folks ask the questions call in get
on the website we're trying to manage
that implement that and secretary
minuchin has said that the paychecks
will be directly deposited or sent and
through the mail to you within a matter
of weeks we also ask the landlord's out
there Lewton and the bank's out there to
show compassion and coordination and
collaboration and and make sure that
there is forbearance here and
forgiveness for folks who are
temporarily in economic dire straits
look these there's been three packages
coming from the hill to the President's
desk in about the last two or three
weeks that he has signed into law those
are meant to provide directly leave to
individuals and industries that are in
specific distress we're trying to give
hope but also money where there is
despair and there will be the president
says light at the end of the tunnel but
there will be the great American
comeback it's not tomorrow it's not next
week but it is coming and Americans will
be part of that until then thank you for
the social distancing thank you for
making simple sacrifices with it for
yourself and within your homes so that
we can mitigate the spread of this virus
okay Kellyanne thank you so much thank
you
stay healthy same to you and yours thank
you thank you